[Music]
here's the thing here's what happened
and passy you have some work to do so
you know how
Chris Cuomo has a show
kind of okay kind of hazardous here's
the thing though
his brother's not going to let that just
go go by no no his brother's not no only
one call when I gotta have a YouTube
matter of fact with Andrew as a matter
of fact with Andrew Cuomo oh [__]
we got both brothers doing shows now the
only way this is going to get great is
if they end up hating each other so much
openly that it becomes like uh like like
where they just do the stream sniping of
each other and then they just keep
complaining that would be hilarious and
they end up they end the beef on
killstream yeah that would be hilarious
they end up on misery loves company
screaming at each other uh Pepsi I'm
gonna need an intro for these
hello and welcome back to look at all
this free stuff the game when he was
governor that he has in his office well
gov fishing see the plate it says gov
fishing ah as a matter of fact I'm
Andrew Cuomo now something I want to
point out is somebody who's very very
familiar with Shore microphones he the
audio source is picking this up is not
his Shore microphone it is his webcam
Mike because he's [__] yeah that's I
don't like dude everybody's been through
that at least once in their life it's
just too come on today with so much
going on the same mic that I'm using
exactly just know how to use it stupid
let's take the opportunity to get back
to some of you know that if he had his
headphones plugged in and had a monitor
of some sort or a friend to tell him hey
man
yeah yeah I think you guys are missing
the point so he doesn't care no somebody
offered him money for a podcast anyway
sure well he's doing good because he's
already up to 1.4 without 1400 uh
subscribers and 860 views that's pretty
good wow
my cats have more than that yeah first
question
okay so there's been so much news about
migrants crossing the board this sounds
fake
I feel like we're not getting the facts
not the true facts what should the
federal state and local this sounds like
a planet call this sounds like this ball
that they put a filter on it to sound
like a phone call yeah
phones don't sound like this anymore
unless you're recording it off of a tape
recorder yeah or you or you right
clicked and then select it all and then
edit effect yeah exactly
old-timey radio effect four but I
believe it's the one they used it's also
just the way he's talking it sounds like
he's faking it like he's not like this
people sound different when they're
genuinely asking a question whereas this
guy is this reminds me of again when in
FM when they'd have the sales guy do War
of the Roses and then you'd have like
you know what I mean some chick friend
down the hall that would all be in on it
because you can't do prank calls
yeah I have a question uh Andrew this is
Chris your [__] brother how [__]
dare you copy me I was doing a show
First Mom's right about you that's why
she called me the handsome One
so how about uh you know no he would try
to do it anonymously yeah exactly okay
so we got uh Chris from Long Island asks
uh he's like yeah hey and he's like
trying to disguise yeah I was just
wondering like what happened to what
would you do like if your brother uh
[__] your whole career up and then uh
and then you have to go independent and
then all your brother came out and
started competing with you at your new
job after you did everything for him and
you know his mother loves him more well
I'll hang up
[Laughter]
it's like oddly specific question
Crystal from Long Island
should focus on hey I got a question for
you Andrew how do I bring a bird back to
life
because like I have a friend I have a
friend I was thinking we would hook him
up to some lightning rods like with like
Dr Frankenstein situation what can y'all
hang up by listening to your answers oh
[__] oh God I'm so happy that they both
have shows thank you that way we can
bring them back as some kind of Franken
bird I don't know
anyway I'll wait for you it's alive oh
housing anyway
uh first Frank Sinatra Stein I believe
is what you're thinking of there has
been so much confusion and
misinformation on this topic it's
frightening I can see one of the reasons
Quake media a big Outlet this is why the
American people are so confused and and
frustrated it depends on also somehow
owned by Conrad Thompson yeah you're
listening to the same you listen to Como
on Quake media brought to you by save
with conrad.com hey Andrew we got a
question from the mailbag now chat me up
on this uh people claimed uh you claim
that uh no old people died uh during
covet when you were Governor but other
people claim that up to a hundred
thousand old people died uh chat me up
Andrew uh what are your comments on that
and uh do you think that uh sting should
have won the belt at starcade nine to
seven well it's funny you say that
ranking member Ruiz
Ruiz select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic thank you for
inviting me to testify today on the
horrific preventable tragedy that
unfolded in Elder Care Facilities in the
spring of 2020 that took the lives of
over 16 000 seniors in New York state
including my husband's parents but
remember he wasn't fired for that he was
fired for grab ass
it's important they remember he was
Mickey and D Newman were married for
almost 60 years I don't hear this we
know old people died it sucks and it's
sad but women do newspaper you read what
TV station you listen to let's take a
step back and actually talk I said it
do you saw that hey guys what's what the
the Adobe free version what's that aside
a side transition a swipe
can we you know what he can't afford the
star swipe that's the premium
it's only a couple look I got power to I
got power director Pro in my phone
Andrew it's like eight bucks a month
it's not hard it's worth it this is not
just an immigration issue
the migrants who are approaching the
Border
are primarily seeking Asylum
from what
because man we lowered the bar for what
Asylum used to do that's the issue it
used to be like no I'm a uh Pulitzer
winning journalist who my uh you know
the leader of my country is about to
have me assassinated if I don't get out
of here and you give them Asylum and
you're like okay come write your book
here you know what I mean but like now
it's just like oh I'm I'm so hungry and
you're like well okay I need a free cell
phone
then they're going so sleepy I need a
home God damn it man
a size to be fair it wouldn't be Mexican
to be Haitians Mexico need to go I'll
work right at 4am I'm gonna cut you
along whatever you need I'll work I miss
the Mexicans they're the best they were
the best illegals I mean you shouldn't
have illegals obviously but the best
illegals were Mexican illegals is
different
Asylum says and by the way it's not
Simon says it's Asylum says so if you do
it when he says Asylum says
Asylum says Asylum says give them free
phones so that's why we're powerless
yeah we have to say Asylum says yeah you
have the right way to hear his Hokey
Pokey policy oh goodness if you put your
right arm in the country you get
citizenship that's it that's it [__]
uh to come into this country if you are
a victim in your country you're wrong
yeah I [__] hate you so much
what it's all about his Hokey Pokey
policy is basically just dual
citizenship for Israel for all politics
oh okay I like that yeah you got one
foot in you got one foot out you know in
case it goes bad Jewish people never
done anything wrong ever in their life
ever in their life and to questions so
we'll get you canceled I know this and I
love you in political prosecution
and you have a right to apply for Asylum
and when you apply for Asylum
you were then given a hearing date and
you have to appear
and the decision is made how about this
Andrew how about this this all sounds so
convoluted and complicated what with the
free cell phones and all the court dates
hear me out on this
hear me Ximena yeah we build a wall and
we kick them all the [__] out that would
cost too much money
I will [__] I know you're kidding
what there is to this day nothing makes
me angrier
than the fact that they would not give
three billion three billion dollars to
completely fix this problem and they're
like we can't afford that and now it's
like we need a trillion dollars for
Ukraine now
[__] man it's depressing or not you will
actually get Asylum now
overwhelmingly the Asylum
gone fishing license plate yes
stupid bro
not paying attention claims cause that's
what I was doing when old people were
dying alone I was fishing
but yeah down a girl's blouse hey I
dropped some nuts down there
this guy can't even eat a sausage around
a woman without it becoming a sexual
yeah sausage is like a penis yes because
he deep throats it in front of them and
he goes this could be you remember that
they did the video Yeah sausage right in
my right leg like a dick like a dick all
right relax buddy it's just food
it is not
immigrants coming to the Border saying I
want to come in just because I want to
live there yes it is
exactly what it is
but you know you lived in Upstate New
York what do you know you're in [__]
Albany hold on a second people coming
you see immigration is not people coming
to live there then it's tourism and
that's tourism it's called tourism see
like Pepsi pessie came down here
remember that I remember like frozen
Asian came down here remember that I
heard she came down they came and then
they like they did some stuff and they
left and they splashed around in the
water a little bit and they went hey
that was a lot of fun we're going home
now I didn't have to do it on my cell
phone and [__] housing you have to
give them a manila envelope and it has a
[__] cell phone in it and it has like
500 cash it's like what is this keys to
a brand new car here you go give him an
envelope and I said with social security
cards his name is now the chico
Chico yep did you just watch that
recently no I just it's like the third
time in my head because it's a good
movie uh Scarface 222 as a Floridian can
we revoke we should watch Coneheads can
we revoke all Asylum Seekers from the
tri-state area
sure uh if by tri-state area you mean
America and yes situations
you guys remember like a couple years
ago when they went down and interviewed
the migrants coming over the border and
we're like just like hey why do you want
to live in America and all of them were
like uh did Buffalo Wild Wings yeah
exactly seriously
that's not real Is that real there is a
clip of a [__] migrant On the Border
going because [__] because they'd
have Buffalo Wild Wings in PlayStation
that's let me tell you something Buffalo
Wild Wings are not that good I
there's a lot of reasons you might want
to come here no no Buffalo Wild Wings
please it's not bad I'm not I'm saying
it's great hey do you want all your food
served in paper containers so they don't
have to pay a dishwasher no thank you
I'm getting boneless wings and drinking
and watching a UFC fight I don't want to
pay [__] 500 for it it's really not
that complicated